dr. sleep is you know and this is
another great project where they've
taken the shining at Stephen King's The
Shining and they've taken the young the
boy the young boy character in that film
and we're following we're catching up
with him later on so it's a sequel
essentially just shining yeah and this
is an amazing project and there's a lot
of the supernatural in this project and
you know which raises the question are
you a believer are you a believer in the
supernatural in ghosts yourself when you
were have you had any experiences that
that you can't explain
I had I did have one when I was younger
yes I don't know what I still don't know
exactly what my feelings are about it
because I think it's easy to be
skeptical about such things but I had a
I had an incident happen when I was at
drama school when I was it was my 20th
birthday and I was living in a house in
Stoke Newington in which is in the east
northeast side of London with four or
five other drama students and I it was a
three storey house a very old house and
at the very top of the house was just
one room on its own that was mine and
then a dark hallway because there was no
windows in the hallway and then this big
flat downstairs that my friend Jeremy
had and I was woke up and everyone it
was Easter and it was also Passover and
everybody had gone home except me and
that was my birthday so I woke up and I
thought was so I went into someone's
room and borrowed their video recorder
and I watched a blue velvet which is a
film I'd never seen and I woke up and I
was running this intense film to watch
film in the morning right along and I
was my birthday and I thought I was in -
it's gonna be an actor and I was
watching this great performance and I
was running a bath and had a robe on I
was just standing leaning against the
door of the the door jamb of my bedroom
and I had a terrible pain on my back
suddenly and I I was in shock I ripped
off my robe and and I the back of my
robe had a huge black burn mark on it it
was singed the whole back and they
noticed intense black burn mark and I
didn't I suddenly thought maybe the
house was on fire or it was a spark or a
flame or so ran all around the house
nothing nothing nothing I think so
I thought that was very odd I was very
unsettled and I took off overnight I
went to pursue my uncle and I from my
birthday night and came back the next
day and I met my friend Jeremy from
downstairs and I was telling him the
story and he went ashen and I said what
is it he went no I don't want to don't
want to tell you or not I made him tell
me and he told me the story that there
was being an old reclusive man that
lived in his flat downstairs and that he
never went out and his brother came two
or three times a week to give him a hot
meal and his brother had got sick and
hadn't come one day and as he got very
weak and he'd fainted in his kitchen
when he was boiling the pot of on his
stove and it set fire to the kitchen and
he'd been dragged out of the building
and he was he died but he was burnt on
his back and I'd been burnt on my back
and I couldn't III I didn't believe him
at first I thought was joking but he
phoned the landlady she told the story
and I listened and then and there's no
real reason why you would or reason
either this burn mark of my back
so we freaked out a bit and we it was
back in the day so he poured us all a
big brandy and we were sitting having
this brandy and as we were carrying the
brandy
back to this because I wouldn't sleep in
my room I was like I'm sleeping in your
room so we were walking back to his
bedroom which was in the old living room
where the old man had lived and I made a
joke about the dust I said look at the
dust in here it's I don't want to use
his real name but I said it's as dusty
as when mr. Goldberg used to live here
and at that point the ceiling of the
lounge fell on top of our heads it came
down like a wave the whole plaster of
the ceiling fell him and I had this
screaming noise and it was me I was
going to say it's okay I heard him
screaming it was me
and I love that and I said to him
afterwards were freaking out and then I
looked I said look at the place and
everywhere was covered with this inch of
dust you know from the plaster and so I
feel like I feel like that was an
unexplained that no other than that's a
really crappy apartment last two weeks
and I was out of there I clearly didn't
want me around mr. no no we should go
find that apartment now yeah even a
really bad yelp review said Airbnb
well dr. sleep we have a clip from dr.
sleep and I don't know that this as I
said this is the the child yes in
Stephen King's The Shining now now your
age and having this experience I don't
know that we need to say much more than
that okay then let's not
[Laughter]
[Music]
now Stephen King's doctor sleep is in
theaters November 8 you and always a
pleasure pocket
[Applause]